seit zwei jahren sucht die
wissenschaftliche initiative
breakthrough listen also quasi
durchbruch hören nach außerirdischen
signalen jetzt hat sie extrem seltsame
signale entdeckt und gleich 15 von ihnen
es handelt sich um fast radiopreis
schneller radio blitze die extrem
seltsam sind bisheriger
astrophysikalische erklärung die
funktionieren also nicht mehr wenn so
viele radio blitze in einer zeitspanne
von lediglich fünf stunden entdeckt
werden was diese signale so besonders
macht und wie es weitergeht jetzt in
klicks und science fiction herzlich
willkommen das signal fast ray burst 12
11 0 2 kurz fr b 12 02 ist wirklich sehr
seltsam es stammt aus einer metall am
zwerggalaxien und ist etwa drei
milliarden lichtjahre von uns entfernt
das heißt diese signale wurden
ausgesandt als hier auf der erde gerade
mal ein paar einzeller herum schon
es dauerte noch eine weitere milliarde
jahre bis die ersten mehrzeller
entstanden von menschlichem leben mal
ganz abgesehen aber wie kann es dann
sein dass aus dieser galaxie ständig
diese extrem kurzen radio signale
ausgesandt werden es gibt zahlreiche
astrophysikalische theorien aber sie
alle können nicht erklären wie sich ein
solches signal ständig wiederholen kann
andere fass rainbirds sind dann auch nur
ein mal aufgetreten und dann nie wieder
was ist hier anders für die breakthrough
insel initiative ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit deshalb hoch dass es
ein signal einer intelligenten spezies
sein könnte eine art backen signale
seien funkfeuer das warnung soll oder
eine art ortsschild ist es könnte aber
auch eine zivilisation sein die die
energie eines ganzen sterns nutzen kann
um zum beispiel riesige raumtransporter
mit solchen radio blitzen anzutreiben
für zivilisation gibt es die katastophe
skala sie besagt welche energie eine
zivilisation nutzen kann
die menschheit ist hier knapp unter dem
wert 1 weil wir knapp die gesamte
energie unseres heimatplaneten nutzen
können ab dem werk 2 kann eine
zivilisation die energie seines
zentralgestirns nutzen und ab dem wert 3
die der gesamten heimat galaxie eine
katastophe zwei zivilisation könnte mit
hilfe ihres zentralsterns solche radio
blitze aus senden und als antrieb für
raumschiffe
fab 12 11 02 wurde 2012 entdeckt und
erst ein paar jahre später wurden in den
beobachtungsdaten die wiederkehrenden
fps gefunden aber so viele radio blitze
wie jetzt mit dem green bank
radioteleskop in west virginia in den
usa beobachtet wurden die gab es noch
nie in so kurzer zeit und noch etwas ist
besonders an den neuen radio blitzen sie
senden mit einer frequenz von 7
gigahertz das ist eine höhere frequenz
als bisher und das forschungsteam hat
jetzt viel mehr daten mit dem digital
backend instrument des green bank
teleskop konnten jetzt verschiedene
gigahertz frequenzen gleichzeitig
aufgezeichnet werden
sie werden jetzt in millionen einzelne
kanäle aufgeteilt und stück für stück
untersucht das kann jahre dauern aber
mit diesen daten sondern endlich
herausgefunden werden wie die fabis die
schnellen radio blitze entstehen und
vielleicht findet das forschungsteam ja
sogar mehr in diesem seltsamen signal
wir halten euch hier auf jeden fall auf
dem laufenden haben mit ihr kein video
zum thema und zu allen anderen themen
verpasst drückt mir hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergesslich den auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter also hier mit aliens
der erste kontakt da geht es darum dass
wir vielleicht schon lange von aliens
beobachtet werden wie bitte ja und das
ist gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich also
wenn er darüber mehr wissen wollt klickt
auf das video und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran